okay
are we here hello
are we live
low high low high
high high low low
low high low
i low
what up guys
happy sunday
[Music]
raga dom
who the heck is ragdom
meant ratadon radicon
is that really
you no
it's not me
you came plus no this is our first
playthrough
hello happy sunday
i'm really good today stan how about
yourself
yay i'm here yay
yay
hi chat
hey welcome
to the stream
okay so by the way
i already lit the forge
as you can see
uh for the video
i didn't have any other character that
was this far in the game and i didn't
want to play through it all again to get
footage so
we've already been to farah missoula
but i didn't do anything there i didn't
beat any bosses or nothing so we're
gonna have to pretend
like we're doing this again for the
stream
okay
okay
good
hopefully that doesn't trigger you
i just really didn't want to play
through the game again you know
morning and thanks for the content just
a question have you seen the seamless
co-op mod would recommend it i have
heard of it i just have not used it yet
but thank you for the five dollar super
chat i really really appreciate that
thank you
and good morning uh i have heard of it i
heard it's really cool i just haven't
used it yet
my friend group uh doesn't really play
this game
that much
they're uh they're on a minecraft binge
right now
how could you do it without us i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i had to
for the video
we're gonna go over here and pretend
okay
fair enough
but thank you again uh quiet bass white
boss i think it's quiet bass thank you
do we know what's over there
what is that
what the heck is that
there's a little top to it
jump no i tried that remember when you
told me to do that on stream three
months ago and i died
straight up died okay all right so we
lit the forge and then we were sent
over here okay i've been through here
though
we'll go through it again
who's the stormlord
probably the stormhawk king but
could be the dragonlord
i've tried seamless it's great
just wish the bosses were scaled up more
so it was harder
but i think it was so much fun so well i
think that would be the point to like
kind of cruise through the game with
your friends a bit you know
terrifying
let's see
i don't think we want to go in here yet
let's just pretend we were sent here
okay
we were yeaded right on over here
so
we still have our list
of many things that we need to do
in
the lakes
hate a lot in caled
mountain glamiere
the plateau
we're getting to the end game once you
get fair in missoula you're definitely
in game so
last time i asked this you guys were
like yeah yeah let's do uh
let's do learning of the lakes
so i think we can go there and just kind
of beat out all these bosses
i think that would be a good idea
where is the knights cavalry in the
lakes
yeah if we want to progress through
ronnie's quest line more i guess we
could go down to knox stella we could
actually bomb that out right now
actually
i think we can finish her questline
for real for real
we'd have to go down under
that's a that's fine we could definitely
do that
what's up with patches we just don't
want to kill him because he's a part of
questline
but he is a boss technically
whatever we're gonna pick whatever chat
wants for the ending so like i'm the
flame of frenzy right now or i'm the
lord like you know i have the flame a
frenzy within me but if chat doesn't
want to do that then we can go and get
rid of it
so whatever chat wants to do
but i'm gonna randomly get in this weird
coffin
why does our character get in here
how does he know to just sit in there
is is this common transportation
yeah we'll do a poll when we get down to
it
they're just sleepy
we should probably question what the
[ __ ] that is you know
we're just like
ah it's fine
we're good that's that's normal here
why does it break as well like it's
broken straight up
like it fell
just gets out like yo what
what's up yoda the coffin
takes you to a salesman asking you about
your car's extended warranty
beautiful that's great
that's great
all right
the deep root depths
so we need to what do we need to do here
we can just go we can beat fia i'm
pretty sure we can go do that
um
oh we gotta beat you
is this a boss
no we don't need to beat him
but we could
oh that's an ant i don't even see it
i'm out
wait
that's just a mushroom
i'm out
if it's not a boss we don't care
this place is really gross
you think there's some lore about the
nobles using coffins
yeah i haven't seen any of that myself
but
it could be interesting
hold up kyle
good morning
yeah this area is really weird right
i think this is just the spread of
godwin's
of godwin right in his as the prince of
death he's just spreading around
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] owl he's beating my ass in
securo i'm gonna have to ask you guys
again what other from software game we
want to play on stream
uh whenever we finish this
[Music]
what up esther how are you today
mama and joy are doing amazing thank you
for asking
such humiliation
[Music]
oh my poor sweet gundyr is not an answer
you should have died a true death
that's the first of the demigods we
could play dark souls 3 in one
to
day
dance
but why
the city had to bring such disgrace
[Music]
play the one where there's a monster
okay
so all of them
riggard
lowell
100 dark souls 3
we could make a clickbaity title that's
like uh
is dark souls 3 better than elven ring
and then play the whole game on stream
and then at the end go not really
it's kind of bad oh we're horny again
these guys are like actually lowkey
pathetic
got our map
we just go straight to fia actually
there's a boss over here
that we could fight
the crucible knight
that i think has a name
and there's also a mausoleum over here
too
ah
get away from me there it is
get away from me your cringe
you just cringe
i beat melania but i compromised my
gamer principles and used bloodhound
stuff to dodge the first part of the
waterfell dance i feel dirty
it's okay dan
it's we understand
that move
is [ __ ] but
it is dodgeable
so i ain't gonna complain about it too
much
play tadpole tails gonna need uh metal
to
to come say that one
isn't there a lift over here
yep i'm so smart i've played this game a
lot as you can tell
where does this go
or chill
chill okay it's just death
we
hey yo what up girl
we bout to fight
we about a fight
why are you playing as godric soldier
i'm not playing a godric soldier i'm
playing rick
soldier of god
oh i'm dead
we died
not yet
i thought he'd stagger
i'm stupid
nice try idiot
boom
easy
is this the place with the screaming
woman
is there a screaming woman in any place
i think you should be proud of that
smavi
nice dude
oh we are owning as the soldier of god
rick
rick's kind of badass don't you guys
think
get mowed
get absolutely mowed all right i'm gonna
try and keep up with this by the way so
we are in
the deep root depth
and we just killed this person so now
let's go kill thea's champions okay
al sucks he's dumb i think he's just
better than you that's why you're dying
to him
stan is your english bad
i didn't know you spoke anything other
than english
even though i knew you're from the
netherlands isn't that cringe
hello
uh oh
i can't see there's a tree
what's that
oh a somber six
i i'm gonna go see what's in this
mausoleum
[ __ ] it now
oh god
made it boys
oh god
oh are these like stuff you can't knock
off here
yeah i don't see any uh
of the thingies
how do you uh open these mausoleums
does anybody know
i'm just looking around
i haven't explored this area very much
this is kind of terrifying
another somber six interesting
you jump on it from the roots
i thought it just knocks you off when
you try to do that oh you actually can
okay
i see it
i see the path
i tried doing that on a different one
and it would just knock me off
so i thought that just didn't work
nerd
open sesame
sesame open
okay like this i'm assuming
oh wow
that works
i can't open it though oh
i see
cool
i learned something new every day
because of you guys
you're the best
it's actually really cool
give yourself a clap chat
you're great
get all these
little it's knocking cove it off to this
thing you know
it's got code
oh i think it's falling yep oh god
oh
all right fair enough
what up silly b
oh you can shoot arrows as well
interesting
hi trey good morning
pray is howl by the way
i've known him since i was five
okay
so is this just yeah same normal dealio
here
okay
same room pretty much
hmm interesting interesting
all right let's get the frick out of
here
oh yeah porn doesn't like it here
hi i am a youtuber and a bad one i have
no subscribers and don't know how to
make good videos
hmm
i don't either man so
just keep
trying
that's what i did i just kept trying
and then something clicked eventually
pretty i would say like the man
i would say
the social media game
is like
who's gonna give up first
and the people who don't give up
make it
so like if you think your content's bad
then it probably is
you you have to like your own content
for it to do well you know what i mean
how do you record
uh obs
open broadcast software
or if you're on console i'm pretty sure
there's just streaming things that you
could do
i wonder if we can upgrade as well i
should probably go check that because i
think we might be able to upgrade
our thingy
who are those bodies in the mausoleum
though i don't know i don't think
they're bot like are they bodies or are
they just like statues
i'm not sure
oh your ps5 then you could probably i
don't know if youtube does streaming
from like an app
but you could stream on twitch
i think
i don't know
just research you'll figure it out
that's what i had to do
sure what's your theory can someone
explain what a mausoleum is yeah it's a
place where you can turn in your
remembrances
uh again so like if you use your
remembrance for runes or an item you can
turn it into a mausoleum to get your
remembrance back
to use for souls again
or
for their second weapon that most uh
demi or the remembrance bosses have so
they usually have like one item or two
items
but you can only turn it in once so the
mausoleums are there so you could get
the other one if you wanted to
or more runes
which is pretty cool
pretty neat
lore wise they have something to do with
resting places for demigods
so
yeah there's a lot there's a lot to it
yeah they're burial tunes
yeah i have a capture card in my
computer that's how i can do this but
yeah yeah let's let's go see if we can
level up our weapon and our our mimic
and [ __ ] like that
why are you over here take a look around
the round table hold is burned yeah i
did that raised to the ground i did that
don't worry
i don't blame you good i'll continue
spirit tuning just the same as before
which is why i need your help persuading
master hughes imagine being a demigod
and then dying
in this place
he won't last much longer if he stays
here
his shackles are broken he's a free man
now i don't know middle aged i hope so
put the round table behind him
hey just so just so you know yoda
saying [ __ ] owl in my chat isn't gonna
like help you kill him
you're gonna have to get better at the
game to do that
low low low low low everyone laugh at
yoda low low lull
if dine's mid imagine dying well
i need a four banger damn okay let's
let's check our weapon
if you die to fia's champions you get
teleported to the dlc
i mean i'll probably die so
we'll test your
you'd be back my theory is that when you
enter the final boss room it's clear
that america and radagon are actually
dead they are dead bodies and in fact
the elden ring lights up ratagan's body
as a hint that it's just the elden beast
controlling its body
no i think that's true too i think
that's like
absolutely a thing
i don't think they're dead
but
they're close
is huge omen
[Music]
i believe he's just a demi demi human
get better at game why are you still
making
weapons as i've always said
you came to challenge the demigods and
their god
to slay them that is me and as long as
you do i will always smith your weapons
oh i was gonna ask you guys that hold on
to smith a weapon for you to slay a god
would you guys want me to play the
quarry
i've heard it's really good
hey where can we get smithing stone
sevens
i should probably look that up
because we need 12 of those
which is kind of [ __ ] insane
or a misbegotten i'm sorry not a demi
human a misbegotten
correct
one level huh health
get gold low
you think they're actually dead the
final boss they're just puppets yeah no
i think there's a lot more puppetry
going on like uh the
the golden order has pretty much used
queen america as a puppet the entire
time which is why i think she
ultimately
betrays them by shattering the elden
ring because she doesn't want to be a
[ __ ] puppet anymore and that inspired
ronnie to also work with her for the
same reason to not be a puppet
ronnie didn't want to be the next
empyrean because of what happened to
america
so they work together to just get
[ __ ] rid of it that's that's what i
think
a lot of people don't think that
a mine in the concentrated okay do we
have both halves
because we could go there
of the uh
[Music]
a luxury key we only have one so that
means we gotta go beat
oh god
all right let's go
we got we gotta beat him anyway right
boys
i'm gonna go play lego marble
superheroes because i'm trash
hey oh true dude
just kidding you'll get it eventually
man
i think sakiro has the best combat in
any
in any from software game
my b style quivers
[Music]
ow
oh [ __ ] i've literally never been hit by
these guys
okay
oh my god
dude that's terrifying
you think in any game ever maybe
but i'll watch if you play the quarry
dude you guys know how [ __ ] scared i
am to put out any other content that
isn't elden ring
you know how scary that is
[ __ ] terrifying
all right i'm not gonna get hit this
time
told you
i'm not fighting that death right bird
yet i'm not doing it
i will not subject myself to the trash
that is this bird that's gonna spawn
right there yup nope
later on when i'm as strong as possible
we will fight it but right now hell no
audio
how can you do all quest lines selling
and headed vermont of conflict so are
you gonna have to choose yeah we pretty
much had to choose we already did that
so yeah
we ended up killing uh jiren
which everyone regretted soon after that
we did that yeah
wait why are you terrified uh to make
any other content that is an elden ring
that is terrifying
what's up renee i think that's how you
say your name do you like eldon beast i
think eldon beast would be a great boss
if we could use torrent
but because we can't it's terrible
i don't think it's terrible i think it's
a spectacle
it's like a spectacle boss but it is
annoying
like it could be better
i think ratagon is
one of the best fights in the game
my audio's bugging again bruh
oh it's because we got a sub let's go
thanks
oh god
renny like that
that audio was bad oh rain okay got it
rain
spamming holy incantations your ass
aboard makes the fight easier
for i think you're a good lord youtuber
you could probably dish out some nice
theories about games like the quarry as
well i mean is there theories
i think that's just a straightforward
game
right
get out of here
ow that hurt
play what you want
yeah that's not
people will tell you that because you
know you guys are trying to be nice
but i know the game bro i've been here
long enough to know that
that's just not how this works
i think it'd be fine to put out center
kind of you gotta you ain't gotta expect
as many views
yeah true
i could just set my expectations low and
to see what happens
excuse me doggies
what's a pedia video
um um
you didn't know this part of castle soul
existed
oh yeah
i always just sprint through this area i
don't know about you guys
that was me
that was me
discord
this is castle soul
stay over there ah
sir
sir you don't know what's happening
okay i will fight you
i'm better than you
better than you
oh not a bird anything but a bird
back it up boys oh my god
jesus
it didn't reach hit
birds are so strong
yes we burned the tree
we burned it to the ground
are you scared for haley tree
nah
hale tree's fine
streamer mode i swear it's on but i
guess it's not
after doing a no summon run for the
first time i hate radical
oh yeah dude
yeah those nights are
not fun
you know mikala has similarities for
yes every everyone's talked about the
similarities to berserk
i hate birds as well
this is castle soul
we're about to fight
a meanie bombing
that we already fought earlier
i don't think the halo tree is really
all that bad
it's certainly hard though
you know molina
it's a good start voice
our uh mimics gonna die though
okay
that's fine
we're gonna take that as it comes
that's not what we wanted however
nice we're gonna take it
that's bad
very bad oh we done okay that's that's
how fast that can happen
and he hits for a lot holy [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah i kind of can stun lock those guys
not him though can't unlock that guy
i can't uh stagger him though why did
you turn around mr lion
stop
oh that hurt yeah i'm out
oh this was a mistake
the boss gives you nameless king
nostalgia
yes
have you s
using nicholas branch in this boss
to the night
in the boss fight
what
sounds good adam good luck
good roll catch
yeah
use d geometry
you guys speaking english
got both of them
both
two for one almost
stop hitting my friend
how did he not die what
oh no
there we go let's use this now
let's go help our boy cause he's gonna
die real quick oh man
man he just turned his ass right over to
me huh
no
holy [ __ ]
now i've barely upgraded the mimic
he's like level four or something
[Music]
how that reaches me i'll never know
please stop swinging
slowly and annoyingly thank you
it's mogan time
i'm dead
[Music]
never mind
what was that
man i thought that would stun them bro
it did not
okay this kind of cat
use of the witching branch on the ghosts
they'll help
i don't know what that what
oh god no i'm distracted i have no more
heals oh my god okay this is gonna be
close boys
dude
how many times i got to hit him
dang it
austin thanks for the uh
279 man i appreciate that
but i understand what do you mean use a
bewitching branch
doesn't that just save your
your stuff
it can turn the boss knights against him
what
no do i not have one
i thought that was the thing that uh
oh that's a sacrificial twig not a
bewitching branch
i mean i almost beat them
these are my consumables though right
i don't think i have any
looks like flowers
yeah i don't think i have one can i
craft one
you can buy five from the merchant below
the bellum church
really
i don't have a crafting kit
below the bellum church huh
isn't that over here somewhere
i mean i'll give it a shot why not
it'll make the boss more fun i mean i i
like the boss just trying to beat it
straight up
is there a merchant down here
hello
oh there is okay
what you got for me friend what do you
need i don't want any trouble i don't
have anything uh let me sell these real
quick
and then purchase
the witching branch
probably gonna need that many attempts
alright
let's go back
so what do i do just consume it
hobo ass yeah
why does the chat keep reloading kind of
weird hold on
should i name my cat
thunk sugan i don't know
okay
yeah that merchant does not want to be
there
uh
you can name your cat whatever you want
use it like a flask
i bet
i didn't send this back down did i
why is your armor garbage
clearly you don't know how to have fun
sir
okay so like
a flask did i just use it in there
there's a closer grace site
how
that one is not closer this one's safer
make sure to equip
them in your loadout it's right here
i'm just gonna go in and use it
okay
did that do anything
why are they still attacking me
ah i see
he's getting freaking own
he died immediately
okay
that was not more fun
if we get more than this
pretty much the same
definitely should have hit him though
oh come on
that sucked guys
oh i haven't used my mimic have a
that was close we'll talk about that one
be nice
i'm so bad
nice
you kind of did it wrong i just did what
you guys said
don't die don't die don't die
of course
oh my god
you
bastard
he wasn't even looking at me man
yeah yeah yeah you guys are backseating
hard right now
just let me fight the boss i'll get it
here in a second
you guys are backseating so hard right
now
i have no idea middle aged
man's not even looking at me still hit
me
just roll bro
how about you roll these nuts in your
mouth
don't say it stan
we've almost got him twice
i'm gonna use this again though
that's so quick
swing faster you guys have fun being
dicks
is that fun for you
just being a poo-poo head
that's so cringe
did i just kill
this was not worth it at all bro
not in the slightest
[Music]
run mimic
he's gonna get really tired here
yep
did that guy promote his twitch
cringe
oh like he can just keep going bro
this guy's strong as balls
okay come on we can get good here we can
get good
is he undead
his face looks like he's undead
come on
we're gonna be smart here
you guys are all being kind of gideon
yep he always does that on that attack
every time
and yet i did the same thing
this one too late
swung too late
bro these attacks are so [ __ ]
annoying okay we're fine fine
keep the distance
holy [ __ ] you guys are backseating so
hard shut up
[Music]
come on do an attack man there you go
can't get him to stagger again
there
he's shut up chat
face
don't play distance you'll get screwed
you see how that was just not true how i
kept my distance and barely got hit
after that
but keep talking man
keep being a gideon see how it goes
dude when people backseat it makes it so
not fun to play this game holy [ __ ] just
let the guy play
first try
to take like three tries
or
i would say bewitching branches were not
worth it but
they are cool i didn't know you could do
that
lord mykolo forgive me the sun has not
been swallowed our prayers were lacking
your comrade remains soulless
i will never set my eyes upon it now
your divine heilig tree
hey look the halogen
tree oh no i'm not triggered at all i'm
not triggered
uh i'm just telling chat shut up
i still chat shut up all the time it's
fine
okay so we got both sides
now
we can go to
the grand live
and go the other way
the sun has not been swallowed my
girlfriend last night
lol
a lull
boy secret medallion
and can we just ban adam like i was
trying to help you dude but now you're
just being an idiot
nobody cares stop promoting your own
channel in somebody else's channel
that's like the biggest dick move you
could possibly do
thank you
my god
here's what's gonna happen and i'm not
dissing this guy's content at all but
here's what's gonna happen he's gonna go
stream to zero people on twitch and then
he's gonna quit
that's how twitch works
should i use summons
you can if you want
this takes you to the consecrated snow
fields
celibacy
yeah i've considered it i just don't
like him so i haven't done it yet
when is there ever drama during these
streams it's not even drama
constipated snow fields
can't poop
worst area in the game i don't know
about that
oh my god
let me be
i don't like him either but why did i
find him interesting
i don't know
very empty
yeah that's fine what do you say
show me the path o gentle lights the
promised path to the halogen tree they
really need to put that there just to
like say hey follow the lights oh hi it
is i antenna i literally reached the
land of michael's hey
where lobo and i began our travels
entirely thanks to youth that i'm so
close to home
these great snow laden lands stretch far
to the north
and beyond the ancient bowers
and the liturgical town of ordna
lies the place that's the worst aerial
area in the game
that town
with the evergales that you have
that you have to light up that's the
worst area in the game
why did we come here
oh yeah we were gonna get the uh
smithing stone sevens which i don't
think we need to do this is the hardest
area in the game at least the halo tree
is
so
let's go finish ronnie's quest
yeah let's let's go fight fia and stuff
i think i think we're fine
i don't think i have enough runes
actually i might let's see
i do
perfect
at least the lights don't reset
peru
it's barren and boring
yeah
did you guys watch the zoli the witch
video that showed these eyes on the side
right here never noticed these before
you see that
there's eyes there
and there's a bunch of other eyes
throughout the world too it's pretty
cool
like you can see the little outlines
right there in the roots
that resemble kind of his eyes a bit
so he's spreading around [ __ ]
everywhere bro
only i don't use sentry's torch
seven and eight ball bearing is in
pharah's
oh yeah
someone told me it was in
honestly i just went with what chat said
we could go beat godskin
when i first saw this
it was really [ __ ] creepy to me man
like this is [ __ ]
terrifying i first time i walked in here
i'm like dude do i have to fight that
thing
you don't
yeah this is so [ __ ] creepy dude
yeah they're on the back of crabs so
they can infect others as well
pretty weird
no
cringe dude
i think cringe a lot
funk
bonk
bonk
[ __ ]
yeah if we have to fight this guy in dlc
[Music]
it's gonna be scary
roger
my friend
[Music]
that's bad
roger stop
i don't want to do this man
it's always the only reason i can see
that corpse for what it is i couldn't
identify squat when i first saw his
course
i mean yes you like mods the game a ton
which is pretty cool
okay you are first
[Music]
not who i want that's not even what i
wanted to do
do it at once do it once
get away get away get away get away get
away get away now
this was a mistake mistakes are being
made
hey mikey
perfect
i rode that guy's shield in the sky
you're dead
hmm
did i've used it bewitching branch on
these guys
boom
first try
is that let me solo her no no no
i fia thanks for that
yeah we kind of [ __ ] him up didn't we
austin ruins elden ring pvp hey i'm a
dex user and i bet my bleed count
couldn't get cooked if you battled me so
i
i one shot most pvp players
dude
do you guys think it's weird that i
haven't even touched
not a single time
pvp in this game
i haven't even touched it
not once
ah
there you are oh wait let me i want to
excuse me i want to i want a lighter
light there we go
there we go
ah
there you are
i knew you would come
what is it do you intend
to deny us and our ways
like the dogmatic brutes of the gold
yeah barry sends you to
moog's
area
i think most people have seen that
no i want to be held you are an odd one
yes i am i am the guardian of those who
live in death
they call me i'm in love with you kyle
and rotten witch
yet you still wish to be held by me yeah
that's not pvp that's co-op metal
and then get invasions i guess but i
guess that's true
that one time
but i've never gone into like to try and
fight other people ever
[ __ ] secret have you ever seen a
hallow brand no when the first of the
demigods died history
marked with the half-wheel wound of the
center bean
hallow brand has since been recovered at
the round table hold
but there is another hello brand out
there somewhere
and i must find it
before the time comes okay let me be
more specific i've never done any pvp
where i purposely like without doing
vary's quest line go in and try and
fight other players is that better oh my
god
are we being cringed today guys when
godwin died
a hallow brand scored his flesh i think
i went in and died three times
another mark in the shape of the
half-wheel wound of the centipede and i
must find it
before the time comes we receive our
lord you gotta be more specific on what
you're saying jake or else we don't
really understand you still let me hold
you
even then
yeah you can always hold me when godwin
died
a hallow brand scored his flesh
but another exists
another mark in the shape of the
half-wheel wound of the centipede chat
is in gideon mode
before the time comes we receive our
lord
when godwin died
a hallow brand scored his flesh
but another exists
another mark in the shape of the
half-wheel wound of the centipede and i
must find it i just need to be more
clear as we receive our lord
yo true
when god wins okay we keep hearing the
same thing now
thank you fear let me go rest and then
we can hug again
and then we'll be good
hey jake just throw the axe just throw
the axe man
yep
you're right
i'll throw the x next time
also hi metal how are you
i don't know why i did that
mommy i need another hug
my instagram is in the description
imagine if there were guns in this game
there's guns in bloodborne when godwin
died but another exists
why don't we keep talking about the same
thing
hello
would you prefer a more balanced pvp or
dlc preferably both that would be that
would be great
you guys know i almost turned on the
webcam today i almost turned it on by
the way
do i gotta hug her again
there's a gun mod i'm sure there is
do the testicle ending
oh my god
we don't deserve both
uh oh yeah we need the curse mark from
ronnie first don't we you're right
you're right thank you chad i'm being
stupid
i'm a stupid idiot
for not remembering
all right we will continue over here
thank you for the help chat thank you
thank you
and now i get to go get yelled at by my
girlfriend
ronnie
i'm just saying i almost turned on the
webcam today
i have the camera set up it's it's
pointing right at my face i just don't
have it on
on obs
dlc lore prediction could be anything i
had no idea i hope it has something to
do with michela or godwin
turn it on then
no
i didn't shower
you're my stupid idiot all right okay
then
yep going to sleep let's just get in a
coffin and fall off a waterfall that
sounds like a great idea
it's so hard to make
lower content for this game because like
do you feel like okay
tell me tell me this chat do you guys
feel like you you're confident in
anything that's going on in the world of
elden ring
like quite literally anything
everything is so [ __ ] confusing dude
it's great
i have like no confidence of
really anything
like yeah we can make certain theories
about stuff you know there's a theory
that every item description is written
by somebody trying to uh
to manipulate us into thinking things
that aren't true
i was like come on man
really
someone said it was like written by the
painter who's trying to [ __ ] us up
mini ronnie
america does have nice titties it's true
you're just stating a fact
all right time to get yelled at you guys
ready to get yelled at
i'm just waiting for a proper vati lore
explanation video i mean he already made
one so
and i watch that video and i go i'm more
confused than i was before
let's get yelled at let's try again
one more time
oh
a dogged fellow aren't we i guess or is
it merely thy habit to talk to dolls it
it's my king fine
fine sorry i hadn't expected any soul to
recognize me in this guys you look
exactly the same that is out the bag
i cannot allow thee thy freedoms why not
perform for me as service as recompense
i didn't even mean to dominate the
baleful shadows which prowl these lands
who's that the name of ronnie the witch
is already sullied by thee i didn't do
anything
disobedience in this matter what does
that mean
okay
just stick her in a jab right
ratagan is a pretty hot chick for a guy
man we are on one today huh
i love it
imagine not knowing everything ever in
this game obviously a casual
yep
true
hello you gross ass celestial bug
ow
i missed
oh that hurt didn't it you forehead
and now you're dead imagine imagine
dying to me
is ratagon male or female
i don't think male or female means
anything in this world not a single
thing doesn't mean [ __ ]
he didn't understand the game himself
whovati
that's what i'm saying i don't feel like
anybody really knows what's going on
it's purposely like super confusing
more than any of the other from software
games in my opinion
and then i'll get a comment saying like
dude eldon ring's story is the simplest
one to understand like are you just
stupid
and i'll go what
what
you didn't answer my question
i mean i kinda did
my answer to that is
i don't think it matters
and i don't care
they're both cringe
there's your answer
do you think the devs know what's going
on
yes
they know what's going on because
they're making a story that's like okay
this doesn't make any sense let's put it
in the game
so they know what and what makes sense
and what doesn't
we talking about hot people why have i
not seen gun deer you are really into
gun beard
i think you can talk to ronnie's doll
here as well
let us speak of the past after a while
i was once an imperial
of the demigods
only i mickeler gender is it yeah i just
don't care what gender you are
i don't care what gender you
as a candidate uh identify as
you do whatever your heart desires
and i hope you're happy that's my answer
i received blithe
in the form of a vassal tailored for an
imperial
but i would not acquiesce to the two
fingers
i stole the rune of death
slew mine own imperium flesh
casting it away
i would not be controlled by that thing
the two fingers and she thought she
calls it a thing
and the baleful shadows
are their assassins
i turned my back on the two fingers
and we have each not sure about your
voice
are there assassins
that's a that's a serious way to come in
here that's a wicked way to come into a
chat for the first time with your name
is
no i'm not dealing with this nope
you can't have that name you just can't
all right
like come on how do you get that name
how
i just banned him
how does how is that not moderated crazy
yo what up guys new here
it's the leader of the nazi regime
what's going on
dead oh you're not dead
now you are
goes glove wart seven
yo i'm soft guys
yo i'm soft bro
[ __ ] soft out here bro
dude i have such a comeback that but
ow
that hurt that hurt that hurt
oh my god
why are we being bad today
why are we doing this
we're being cringed we're being toxic
we're being mean
stop it
sent you a picture of chat hey let me
check twitter
let's take a look ski here
[Laughter]
it's the derpy spongebob that's that's
that's right on the money man that's
[ __ ] hilarious
retweet
thanks man
derpy spongebob
yeah i'm soft for banning a guy in chat
named adolf hitler
shut the [ __ ] up even when i turned my
back upon the two fingers
elith remained my loyal ally
though he was created a vassal for an
aryan
he was a colossal failure on the part of
the two fingers
blind at least you guys are fun
art willing to give too much to me
yet
they both understand
what lieth beyond the dark path
that i must betray everything
and rid the world of what came before
should i add thee to the list why is she
being mean to me
kind of heart
as kind of hard as they
ah
this form has loosened my tongue
i've slipped too much
forget what thousand
forget
i think the lack of any major timeline
for events and how weird the story is
compared to other games is george r
martin's biggest touch in eldon ring you
know besides all the
insects
yeah
yes eg is a shadow bound
given to ronnie from the greater will
yes
oh everybody uses us in this game by the
way ronnie is no exception like ronnie
uses us hard
if you guys haven't noticed
but everyone sees a blue doll for arms
and they're like all right
i'll do anything you say
why does everybody die in this game
i see this is your first from software
game
oh shadow
thou art the
that last the witch cut off the delay
drench thy flesh
with a fateful wound
there to heal
hmm
three
no i can do that
not you
i believe we saved bach by calling him
beautiful
we did that last stream right
no this isn't this isn't blind
it's this beautiful shadow
i mean technically it's blood you know
what it is
thanks
own it was more of a challenge than i
envisioned it's like blind 0.5 it's a
good way to put it before them
this is farewell my dear
tell blythe
and eg
i love them
do we tell em chat do we tell them that
um
[Music]
oh do i wanna go through here yet
beautifully fought
sorry i'm reading chat miyazaki and the
team wrote the current events of the
game and events of the past elden ring
the shattering are from george rr martin
yeah i don't know like do you guys think
that because the game was written
in parts from george rr martin and parts
from from software where i'm sure there
was a language barrier issue there since
the entire firm software team is
japanese and i don't know if george rr
martin speaks japanese i'm sure they had
a translator but do you think that led
to like some kind of
kind of
stuff not really matching up or making
sense like i
you know i i like the story it's really
cool but there's a lot of [ __ ] that does
not make sense to me you know
it's tough to understand what was the
deal with mini ronnie
uh
just another doll that her spirit took
over for a short amount of time
you don't think that
most likely
i died to phantom blight like 15 times
i'm sure i did on my first playthrough
too i know how to do most boss fights in
this game melania is still gonna be
really hard with this build but we can
definitely we can get it done
we can get it done
i know ronnie's inning was heavily
mistranslated i i did hear about that
yeah
they screwed up ronnie's ending yeah i
know they screwed up ronnie's ending but
i wonder how much more they screwed up
you know
i'm not talking about just
mistranslations i'm talking about stuff
that just doesn't make sense together
like maybe it makes sense in the
language of japanese but maybe it just
doesn't make sense in english you know
what i mean
because you know words mean different
things in different languages and
cultures and i i don't know
i this is definitely like i find the
dark souls series to be very easy to
understand
whereas i find elden ring really [ __ ]
hard
they're living in jars yeah yep
yeah we'll definitely do a randomizer
stream for sure that'll be fun
okay
let us continue i have
one of these
range um
is it gonna hurt us that bad should we
go fight the dragon skin
let me go
let's uh
yeah we're gonna play bloodborne on
stream as well we definitely are
i have a ps4 we can use
yeah i'm like reluctant to even walk out
here
this area is uh
dark souls much lore is much deeper and
profound than eldon ring's lore see why
do you think that though because it
seems like elden ring's lord just goes
deeper and deeper and deeper every time
i look into it and it confuses the [ __ ]
out of me
that's that's what i'm thinking lee
dive in aight
the lady has spoken
yeah let's just finish we're here to
finish ronnie's questline let's do that
let's do that part
[ __ ] it
dlc's in there all right bucko
how would you consort a spirit you don't
it's all a lie
dark souls lore comes full circle while
eldon ring is some turtles all the way
down
yeah
light town is worse than lake of rot
uh we'll have to explore more of this
area i've never really taken a hard look
at it this area at all
because it's tough to navigate but i'm
sure we can
craft
imagine lake of rot but in 10 frames per
second that's blighttown
yeah i think dlc can really open up the
lore or it can make us even more
confused than we were before
no idea fam
uh i'm good s how are you
ow
my ass
yeah we're gonna we're gonna come back
and uh fight everything
i wanna grab
never mind
gonna grab this real quick
yeah should we play the uh the fan made
bloodborne game that would be really
cool
yep
more confusion equals more content
hey i'm not worried about any of this
[ __ ] as a content creator like that's
great i'm just i'm i am just trying to
understand the game i would love to
understand what's going on
content-wise
yeah
only an 8 out of 10 burp
i'll do better next time
will we get will we ever get a story
conclusion as great as slave night gail
no
they they couldn't have done better with
gail bro
in the dark souls series that that was
perfect
i platinum elden ring a week ago and i'm
now trying to platinum bloodborne nice
dude is it your first time playing
bloodborne
exactly spades yeah
we got a lot of content that's for sure
dark souls fbs update for new gen
console i mean there's a dark souls
remastered
it's pc though i think
this is where i've been for a month
all right we're gonna first try it just
for you
you just haven't played you'd beat this
guy in an hour
you're good at the game
i have any um nope i don't
you gonna do it for ps5 there you go
oh
question i'm gonna make a poll for this
actually
do you guys still play elden ring
how often
do
here let me do this do you still do you
still
play
elden ring
and i'm gonna make a few options here so
it's gonna be like
yes
every day
sometimes
not at all
just watch content
i'm curious what you guys say
because i still play this game every day
get an fbs update
i think those are good options so every
day sometimes not at all just watch
content
i don't know why i made do in capital
letters
do you still play alternate
so
yeah this is what i thought it would be
that you guys still play it sometimes
you're just not playing as much as as
much as you did right
no i just finished it again a week ago
from a new character and it was super
fun okay
yeah it's mostly sometimes okay
there
waiting for dlc yep yep
this is this is what i thought it would
be
because i noticed the player base went
down
heavy
heavy down
uh it's mostly a single player so
here's my next question do you think
that
you would play the game more if there
was more dlc
or not dlc not excuse me not that
uh more of a pvp that wasn't
because my understanding from the pvp
especially from zio storm stream or
video is that pvp is not enjoyable at
all
i haven't even touched it so i i haven't
touched it barely at all so i don't know
good luck on that level one run gamer
good luck
it's gonna be tough
it's gonna be tough
where's that i can't right now due to
college but i will play it again
afterwards option i i got you lone wolf
i understand
pvp is tough to get into see that's what
i thought
like i i i didn't touch it in any of the
other games either i'm just not a pvp
type of guy
yeah it's just rivers of blood moon veil
still yeah
that's that's what i keep hearing anyway
i would play
the game more if i didn't have
depression
oh this game fixes depression
doesn't fix it
but uh i love this game
i have too many games to play so i'm
working on your backlog
that's that's what i thought
you don't think it's a game issue it's a
community issue gotcha
i i think that's that's probably it
because imagine if everybody in the
community was like no
let's not yeah it distracts from
depression it helps yeah yeah um
imagine if everyone in the community
said all right let's not use rivers of
blood
but that's not gonna happen is it
imaginable was like okay we just won't
use rivers of blood
and then they didn't
that would be like
your key that you you're in an amazing
community if you could get that to
happen you know
oh my ass
that's more my face
all right come here big boy
idiot
i don't know what this is
i remembered what that was
ow
yeah i really want to try seamless co-op
that looks really fun
nice
let me over his leg
hit
that sucks
he's out he's out
yeah this boss is really really cool
uh oh
oh
[Music]
not what i needed there
yeah my mimic is going strong bro
[Music]
owned
give me that eyeball
oh it's not dead it's not dead
there we go
yay first try
pvp in these games has always been
broken with op meta dark souls has
horrible backstab terrible connection
yeah
through
all right everybody is required to call
me daddy now i don't care how cringe
that is metal babe has spoken you all
have to call me daddy
thank you
favorite boss looks wise my favorite
boss looks wise is probably that one ass
asil
blessing on let me get let me get that
out of here
bro uh
you forgot the ring
oh no
whatever shall i do
oh i'll just go get it
just kidding
i was being kind of mean there i
apologize can we get some bloodborne
playthroughs daddy yeah let me finish
this dude we can absolutely do that
[Music]
dark moon rain acquired
i like ds3 modding community with jesus
flying around in people's games and
smithing
i definitely want to mod this game it
could lead to some pretty cool content i
think
i call you jake or lord of lore
dude vati is the lord of lore i'm not
even close to his level of
content my opinion
eldon beast looks cooler i think he
looks like a big dildo
like a big celestial
dildo
probably upgrade the endurance a bit
kind of looking good everywhere else um
let's go back home
vati is retired
no he's not he posted like two videos
two weeks ago
man's a legend i see
you're here for some spirit tuning
probably
i don't have a four yet bro
penis beast
let me
use you
i didn't use you i can just sell it it's
much easier
you guys tell me that every time i pop a
rune
just because i like the sound of it
and strengthen still don't have sevens i
don't i think we're good
maybe not the lord of lore but an
aspirant of lore instead
i'm doing my best man i'm glad you like
it
[ __ ] vati his [ __ ] is always ass
backwards and makes no sense
at least you take your time to make
things connect i don't agree with that
at all i think his videos make way more
sense than mine
i mean the last video i made everyone's
like no
wrong
ronnie is actually gwyndolin who
traveled through the painters painting
which is the our bloodborne skiro world
combined and brought darkmoon with him
hey maybe man
maybe
potential
yeah botsy's videos are really good like
really really good
also we're two different creators
there's no point in like comparing the
two
very similar content though
okay let's go back
what does eldon even mean
uh like ancient
old
older
i believe is the definition
you can use your runes instead of
selling them
so you're just saying the opposite of
what you guys tell me to do all the time
okay got it
that's fun about theorizing it's debate
of opinions
yeah the point is the the ending thing
you said there bro like
if both sides are civilized
i've gotten death threats about my
theories before so
you know
and that's because uh people are
mentally insane some people are
remember getting an email that was like
this is the worst video ever made makes
absolutely no sense you're the worst
creator i've ever seen you should commit
scooter ankle
like well
all right then
that's just being a content creator guys
if any of you are wanting to go into
being a social media content creator
whatever you're just gonna have to deal
with [ __ ] like that
it just is what it is people are insane
especially online
what does ring mean
yeah dude it's not even a full ring
it's not even real
die dragon
just gonna stand there
what the hell just happened that was
sick
yes soldier brick
my boy gets it
oops that's a problem
oh
are you gonna go we gonna do are you
gonna go what are you gonna do
oh this is the moon thing yeah yep
oh didn't dodge that correctly
oops
i'm done
we're fine i [ __ ] up though
oh not again
that would have been so cringe if i fell
there dude
can't reach you bruh
i do know bricky
ricky is one of my favorite creators
i'm the best
mic level 105 or something i think maybe
a little more
oops
boom
yeah i think the devs over did it on the
dragon fights too i feel the same way
do you guys agree with my theory that um
ronnie's two fingers fell from the sky
when we killed radon and that's what
radon was holding up in the sky because
this just looks like it just fell
straight first into the ground
was in there and then ronnie went in and
killed it with the finger blade
with the finger blade
finger slayer blade
i
some people told me that's not right but
man i
just makes a lot of sense
it just looks like it fell from the sky
with all the starlight shards everywhere
just bursting through the ground right
here see like
yeah
i mean it fell from [ __ ] space
ronnie had 20 fingers
looks like a natural hole to me where do
you see the naturalness of this hole
where it clearly just destroyed this
place
and just went boom
deep down
radon put her fingers up in the sky
because it knew it would hold her fate
back or her destiny
because she needed to kill her two
fingers and radon didn't want her to do
that so he put it in the [ __ ] in
space
that's my theory
yeah the stars are carrying royalty
which is ronnie
that's that's
that's ronnie as well
when you when you talk about the carrion
royals that's that is ronnie as well
hi pascal how are you
imagine putting radon
imagine radon putting his fingers okay
dude
nope way too far way too far there buddy
it sounds logical but do we really know
not really
yep
i think her great rune uh is
is the moon or a version of it
yeah it just crashed through here
maybe tried to dig its way out and then
ronnie found it down here and killed it
because you can see that
it she sliced it up with the finger
slayer blade like she cut it right there
all the way through it and now it's it's
actually dead
and then she's just there now
i think it makes sense but i guess some
people don't like that theory
but now that she has the finger killing
blade we'd have to end radon now he's
crazy to release the fingers so she can
kill them
yeah
yeah that's why she wants us to kill
radon so that he can release the two
fingers from space
comes crashing down
and then
maybe has been down here since and then
ronnie just kills it slices it up
it's our waifu
it's our waifu
no i don't think
i don't think anybody in this game is a
villain besides the dung eater
and gideon
because ronnie has her own
ideals her own beliefs her own values
and radon has his it doesn't make them
villains they just
want different things it doesn't make
one or the other bad you know
yeah radon just wanted a
an honorable death and we gave it to him
yeah shiburi as well
i mean maybe
we don't know enough about it i guess
they do want chaos so yeah
yeah
hi waifu
[Music]
waifu
so it was thee
who would become my lord it's me perhaps
i needn't have warned thee
i am pleased however
sowered a fitting choice
i am pretty cool to the night sky
will you kill ronnie
i think i bit thee even if we tried we
could never kill ronnie i think ronnie
might be the most powerful character in
this game
once more
all right let's get our dog [ __ ] sword
it's actually a cool sword
let's go
guys stop being weird good and evil are
way too simplistic concepts i yep agreed
but is this another hole
wait
this is where it came from right
oh
this is how i can walk out of here
obviously
all right
good job guys we did it
we did the thing
hey what was that dragon's name
what was it called
like can we see it here
no not really
let's update our thingy
our list
so that was
sorry
got the sniffles
so we killed
these champions
uh ratagan of the golden order eldon
beast no
[Music]
this would be up here right
that's a doula okay thank you
so this account is this area abdullah
right here got it awesome awesome
awesome
then we want deep root or lake of rot we
killed actual
perfect we kill anyone here no not yet
just want to give it a bit of an update
oh we could go do this boss fight yikes
we killed the onyx lord killed moog in
lane dell
okay we'll just have to update this more
as we go along
classifics
uh it's in the description
you want your own checklist
and follow along
there's another moon to the side
oh this is a good view
it's like do you guys see a great rune
in that like kind of right there you see
that like kind of like the outline a bit
because we know she threw it away but
did she throw it away in [ __ ] space
how could she be so powerful oh we need
to go do that we need to go here
let's go let's go see what's going on in
jarburg real quick see what's going on
up in in jarburg
hello
jar barn
oh my god melissa
oh
hello again cuz hi i'm happy you came
back yeah i have good tidings for you
cuz you do have you noticed the rare
flowers growing in this village no i
asked the villagers if you could pick
some of them
and they said you'd be very welcome
you killed everyone in jarburg by
accident
you
demon
go on cars
you really should pick some of our
flowers
who knows what's up sub-zero might be of
some use
okay
oh
[Applause]
he's playing fortnite oh i'm so sorry
i didn't think that would hurt you
are you okay
i'm so sorry he was just plain
oh
i feel so bad
when you play a little bit too hard
all right that's enough flowers
jesus gorham calm yourself
i took his flower
took his dad's flower too
go on cars i did who knows
let me go rest
bloodstar related to the formless mother
is that a flower
why do the flowers glow
because they're pretty
ah
hello again i say cuz
have you met uncle alexander yeah he
used to live here with us but then he
left to be a champion oh my god he's
inferior missoula right now
but he said
the path of champions must be trod alone
so heroic right
i miss him though
if you see him uh you should ask him to
teach you how to fight cuz
he's big and tough and strong
uncle alexander said he won't be back
again
my home is of the past and the past as
they say
is a different country
i suppose that's part of being a warrior
isn't it
so
please don't tell anyone cuz
but
i'm actually a warrior jar as well
one day
i'll be just like uncle alexander and
i'll have to leave the village
to become a champion
sorry
um what's that over there
i was looking at my phone
i just killed the alice at the lake
don't know if that's true but i heard
it's the only way to keep jarvik safe
i believe so yeah
we actually stopped fighting him is he
here yet how do how do we get him to
come here
let me just take your stuff guys thank
you very little i appreciate it
how does he get to pharaoh missoula
i'm gonna sneeze
sorry my sneezes are obnoxious
what
i have no idea
like i said in the last video thinking
logically about how stuff happens in
this game is just going to lead you to
getting headaches
okay what happens if i rest and go
talking like
hey jack my name is not jack
finally live watch your latest last
completionist videos and i love it
thanks for your content you're such a
good guy
i'm glad you like it man thank you
don't call me jack ah
hello again hi do you know what a
poacher is cuz no they hunt us
smash us
and then take us away
this village is kept secret
so
i think we're safe here
but you should be careful if you ever
meet one of them cause
i hope uncle alexander beats small up
first
i think we gotta go fight alexander
yeah
let's go do that that sounds fun
let's go
how do we get up to where alexander is
because we can see him from here
who should we call you
you can call me jake
that's good
there he is
freaking chilling oh we can go this way
let's see
gotta take that and go over there or we
can go up there and jump over there
you guys ready to cry
yeah we started pheromone
i'm gonna kill him
are you gonna cry
just kidding not that big of a dick
um
he's just big chilling he's just looking
around man having a good time
i believe there's a ladder
not here
die
cedar
you're cheating
please don't
it must be done
where's the ladder
the knot here
oh it's down there isn't it
in it
rip jake from state farm do you guys
know that was my old name
and then state farm was like you can't
do that
try to get behind you oh my you are dead
as hail
ladder what yeah i thought there was a
ladder back there
i love how it just
freaking annihilates them good
i think i'm thinking of somewhere else
so hold on
i can't go back up there so there's no
point
you want to be friends with the beastmen
that's a little weird
considering
they're dead
yeah you can like what you like you know
[ __ ] it
stone sword key to alexander ah okay
is it over there
down here
over by your mama
[ __ ]
i didn't jump far enough
is really cool
give me those back thank you
just ash old
stop it
damn these things are beefy
[Music]
i'm gonna jump a little far there my guy
thank you
[Music]
nice try
stupid idiot
yeah i wonder can we even beat the
godskin duo like this probably
you
i just hit him so hard he's on the other
side
probably could have let him live and he
would have fallen off
head to the next
game hop up level work
back to alexander what
their ladder right here
would you look at that i don't think
this goes up to him though
he's a little bit higher up
hello
goodbye
ah
i see
there are worm faces like over there
i think we have to go
damn it
i'm heading in the right direction
i don't think we can go anywhere in here
can we when these guys pop down
ah it doesn't lead to anything i don't
know what they're doing
head to the next game hop up a level and
i just don't know what that means
man i have to go i have to be godskin
first okay
[Music]
dude
how the [ __ ]
he lets you murder him and wear his
trinket just to make rivers of blood
even cheesier giga chad friend
he really is a giga chad
you think playstation plus is worth
getting i don't have it so i don't know
oh god
no my nose
[Music]
[Music]
whatever okay
are you sure we have to beat godskin
first
to get to alexander
it's up there hold on
yeah every time i die i like try to i
don't know i'm cringe
some of you are saying yes and some of
you are saying no
so now i'm just confused
you kill him and then you unlock the lip
i think we can get there earlier guys
we're gonna we're gonna i'm gonna look
around
look around a bit
hey
sir that hurt sir
sir
hello
hold on
not
it was a tiny bit
thank you
it is warm in here
appreciate it
okay
now i'm lost my my mind is
elsewhere okay
people are saying no are dirty liars
cats
you wouldn't lie to me would you
press one in chat if you'd lie to me
can you summon bernal for the godskin
duo fight is that true
a yo for real for real
69
that's the funny number
that's the sex number lol
oh my god
so do you just insta stagger
looks like it
[Music]
go back it's like i swear you can hop on
a fallen column and go up
all right well you know hold on hold on
no
i'm exploring
yeah worm faces are a bit weird
so a column over here
nah that looks sketch af bro
um not there
nope okay i'm going back down
why does godwin have eyes and pherom
um i mean he probably infected it before
baromizula moved
you know what i mean
okay so we can't go up there
what is that area
i don't want to go up there yet
yeah the the sounds these guys make are
really creepy
what's that uh
oh
is he in the tree what the [ __ ] is going
on
where is this ladder there it is
i found it
died
whoops
anything but a [ __ ] dog
bruh
there we go almost died
okay let me go here
yes you can summon him
congratulations on 60k thank you
we're almost at 63k i mean
getting a lot of subs every day i really
appreciate it guys thank you
in their models which means uprooted
maybe they literally corrupted her tree
roots been pulled out of the ground
there's a potential
oh do i hurt this guy i feel like he's
just chilling
it's kind of sad
i'm gonna leave it alone
so that's where i was
how's your dog
joy oh she's amazing
joy's doing fantastic thank you for
asking
what are they praying toward are they
just like
dying
the godskins might be really rough with
this build
no i did not play ghost wire
okay
this looks somewhat promising
this is just back where we came from i'm
lost
i don't know where i'm going
let's keep looking around
it's over here
i miss torrent can't use torrent
leave me alone
yeah we're about we're trying to find a
way up to alexander
what is the best boss in video game
history
we're done
i don't know i'd have to think about
that one
sleep pot
i don't think we can get up to alexander
from here so maybe whoever said you have
to be uh
pass godskin duo maybe they were right
this is just a new character
soldier of god
his name
art thou rick
any lore video in the works not right
now i really want to finish this
playthrough
imagine being this guy
my goal right now is to finish this
playthrough so we're going to be
streaming get him out
i
i think eachine is the best boss ever in
from software
gail's sick i love gayle [ __ ] gayle's
awesome oh let's go to the other
the easier
place
saw soldier godric 100 plus versus
melania and he almost killed all of them
and he almost killed all of them
whoa
interesting
[Music]
i like those videos
modding this game is so cool
sister freda versus melania
i think melania wins just because she
can heal
shut the [ __ ] up everyone shut the [ __ ]
up
[Laughter]
got him
oh
lady is a cheater
it's not her fault though
you have to be god's can do it with him
upstairs go forward okay
i guess you were right
peep the new lore video and saw soldier
of godric in there a few times maybe
laugh
yeah right
like with this character in the video
yeah
did you guys see like me doing the dab
on fia's bed
nobody pointed that out and i thought it
was funny
this area is kind of
we are here to reach out to you about
your car's extended warranty
cringe
oh
i think
maybe sister freda in stage three can
beat melania that would be a cool video
if someone could like figure out how to
do that
i don't know if that's possible
damn
colossal weapons just
bomb through these guys
i am playing as the soldier
of godric yes yes i am
my name is rick
monk bonk
bonk
godskins theme song is the best in the
game
imo
how do i get to that little offset area
where am i where am i missing it
if i enter here yep
hidden
yes i have jack it's pretty cool
uh you don't need to be the god skin
just go to the dragon temple lift at the
top is a grace
dragon temple lift at the top is a grace
from that grace go follow the path right
and follow till you find alexander
i'ma believe you dog
this is all on austin
if he's wrong we time him out for the
rest of the day thoughts
i'm going right
going right
wrong
just kidding um
oh
can i do this move is this possible
why would i do that okay
metal get ready so did you say down
that grace go out follow the path right
and follow till you find alexander dude
we did that and could not find him
that's not the temple lift jake
dragon temple
all right where's the lift then
the lift is through a stone sword wall
okay where is that
is that in there somewhere
in this area
the lift is after the godskins that's
what i'm thinking
her boys right up
there yeah isn't that past the godskins
he's saying no
i think he's right
okay he's saying you don't
i don't know
just fight the dumb boss bro just just
fight the dumb boss bruh
come on bruh
hey there's like a way easier way to get
this fight though and i'm not
remembering where the entrance is
okay we're definitely gonna die but
let's just see how it goes
you
[Music]
howie
howie
this is unfortunate
ah
yes nice dude let's go rick
never seen that attack from him ever but
we did it
[Music]
snap him back baby
snap crackle pop
oh that's branch oh
wait
that's the scritch
i'll see you to death
you're just so much easier to fight
[Music]
oh you're running i see i see we're
running now
that's just not how that should have
gone
[Music]
almost clutching out here
that's one no
my heart
oh
we were doing so good
oh
my heart
where do i summon bernal
is that actually thing
oh that was so good dude i couldn't see
him
alright is it over here
a little offset entrance
no
that was so good though oh my god
it's a one aggros at a time
jump down those stairs right here okay
got it
oh and then down here
ah
see you guys you guys are smart huh you
guys are smarties
you know if i were a teacher i'd give
you guys smarties right now you got you
guys know what candy that is
want some smarties
we can have a parties
you don't know what smarties are i feel
bad
it's by one of the fog walls
okay let's go over here
oh yeah this is like a totally different
area isn't it oh yeah oh yeah
hi anthony how are you
no
yes
you could calm down sir
sir calm down sir
yeah yeah let's just keep spinning
let's just
how many spins did he do there
jesus
i did like eight spins
all right i'll just run through no
fighting
windmill
you spin me right round baby right round
like a record baby
when we go right round
you spin my head right round
cool this is fair i like this this is
fine
i'm not seeing the drop point here
somber 9 holy [ __ ]
nice
nice
nice
this way
good good running we're running away now
going this way
stay up there
i didn't know you could summon bernal
for this fight you guys just taught me
that i found it i went the wrong way you
can yell at me now
oh this is not what we need
just just kill me
finally shut up myro
shut up
that's all i have to say to you sir
finally i mean i know exactly where that
was but this streamer didn't dude
finally
just kidding you're great all right
where's bernal
probably not here
maybe he's up here
this is this is wall hander zilehander
hey
it's our boy
i
let's get it
i'm gonna summon my mimic as well
cool
[Music]
that went horribly wrong
i went for the uh
anything other than that
okay
okay
[Music]
perfect
yeah is bernal owning
nice
so
[Music]
we'll take it
wrong thing
let's go bernal oh
locking on would probably help yep
let's go bernal
nice
what a legend
okay we killed him before he could
summon what does that do
i think that should end the fight there
don't you guys think
if you can kill both before one summons
[Music]
almost died there
man bernal just shreds dude holy [ __ ]
and you're back
not fair
bernal is a legend
[Music]
nice
oh
you find the pillar
i'm not even hitting him there am i
nope
[Music]
what's up
rattle how's this fight not over we've
killed him four times
me and our boy bernal
soldier of god rick and bernal
teamed up
for the
best objectively the best boss ever
right i i'm glad they made it easier as
i'll say about that
good stuff chat flaps in the chat for
bernal bernal is a legend
yep that's what we needed boys
let's go upgrade
let's go upgrade
oh you i see
nope still don't have a four
that's okay
oh wait
yeah we're gonna need 12
sevens
[Music]
you guys like it when i burp in your
face
i booted
how are you
i killed him at war master shack
well
bet you regret that now don't you
don't check
seven so we need 12.
four
five six seven eight nine
eleven well
see how uh like i made that way harder
by just not going up to item 12
and i just counted out 12 like an idiot
did that trigger you
frick are you
oh smith as long as you lie
okay now we need
three
nine eights got it
nine eights
do you guys like how my mods love each
other isn't this great isn't this fun
people counting sets me off man that's
yeah it's so annoying when people do
that one two three four five six seven
eight
need one more
so annoying
how about when people pop runes instead
of seldom
all right
struggle with placid deuce axe
let's go fight alexander
oh
i don't have rooney boys dude i don't
have rooney bullies
what can i sell um
get rid of this bewitching branch
okay
i'm just not going to do that we're fine
we can come back when we get more rooney
voice so
we need more negative energy somebody
calls somebody a bum face poo poo head
um
i would defend her with cole's life
i never struggled with any god skin
because i used heavy bleed yeah then
you're good bro weren't you the guy that
says
you go into pvp
uh with rivers of blood
wasn't that you
kill bernal and then resurrect him as
via turtle pup
i don't think you like that counts
because he attacks you
you don't accidentally attack him
oh
other question do you guys want to go
fight blight or is that going to make
you cry
can't we fight blind now
yeah we're getting to the end game yeah
we actually are
can we fight blight now
imagine
all right let's go make people cry
i'm sorry pascal i'm so sorry
i need the runes
oh
is eg okay
is he mad chillin
hey good
oh there you are
good of you to drop by
have you heard
lady rani has departed on her journey
along the dark path of the imperium
from rana's rise
as she i did it for the money it would
not have been possible without you
as lady irani's war councillor and
moreover
her childhood warden prepare to cry i
express my deepest gratitude
you and only you
were ladylani's true champion pat
yourselves on the back chat pat
yourselves on the back you did that you
guys did my purpose is nearing its end
i've served lady rani for as long as i
can remember
it has been a long and wonderous journey
now lady rani is in your hands
i pray that you serve her well
until the very end i'll do my best daddy
all right
i feel so bad for blind bro this is
actually one of the saddest parts of the
game
is this
no matter what might happen
ronnie
she makes me
oh my god
hey look
dead assassin
lied
no
lied
wide
i'm sorry
no
dab on them haters
you thought i was sad
huh
wrong
was that too far
we put him down for his own good guys
good dab
oh let's see how cell this is doing
ah
it's all going according to plan
our boy did
ooh these could be cool
well
goodbye
all right let's get the
his helmet
here i'll make the furries happy here
for a second hold on
where is it
here
wait
who is this
is this the real blind
before he was taken over
just kidding that's not actually a thing
all right i'm gonna make the the furries
happy for a second there you go look at
that wow
back to rick
[Music]
blight is my least favorite character in
elden ring how
are you okay in the brain
how do you not like blight
yeah at what point do the assassins come
and kill him
i don't remember anyway let's continue
infiram azula
we
that's even worse
i've used the wolf mask ever since i
found it hey listen it looks great it
really does
that's not our build
i don't think eldon lords are given
shadows are they they're given um
i mean nothing empyreans are given
shadows right
so weird
yeah beast regents that's what you're
given
well that was not because of the elden
lord
because you're elden lord that's just
because uh godfrey needed it right
rip dog
okay yeah see this is where we can go up
to alexander yeah
over here
right
no this way
what the [ __ ] is that
oh just a statue that [ __ ] scared me
man
oh ratagon's red wolf maybe you guys are
right
might be tripping
this dragon press is really good we have
here this is maximum xp greatly raises
stamina that we don't really need
we're okay on that
vastly boost physical damage negation
it's very good
i think pharamazol is in another
dimension as well
cool i'm dead
um
i have to go back up right
brick man
i go all the way back though
hold on
exploding
leave me be
anything but a dog
let me just go get this and then i'll go
back up
by killing malagath has no effect on
garank
yeah i i think this area
is outside of
the normal time frame like time never
changes here it never gets it never gets
dark
the the sun's always up it's always like
this
wait if your soldier is soldier of
godric does that mean your soldier's
name is nope
i don't think so
yes it is visible but that's what people
didn't understand about my latest video
is that um
i said that i i know that you can see
pharah missoula from melania's divine
tower
that doesn't matter i think there's a
different version of pharah missoula
depending on when we're here and when
we're not here so even though we can see
it
from a divine tower that doesn't mean
it's the same does that make sense
i got that comment on my last video
hundreds of times and it's really
annoying that nobody understood that but
i guess that's my fault for not
explaining it well enough
sun never changes here
yeah i said that in the video and nobody
understood it unfortunately
oh smithing seven
i didn't need that earlier
we're fine okay
wow
no it's okay nobody saw that in the
video for some reason no i said it
i just didn't explain it good
enough that's my fault people wouldn't
say it if i explained it good enough
nope i disappointed all of you that's my
fault i am sorry
i will do better
in the future
hey this has got to be it
i have i totally do
oh not enough
raw okay
favorite souls born game other than
alden ring bloodborne
definitely bloodborne
yeah i can get it from a merchant
absolutely
i just can't leave when these people are
aggro
hey
there we go
is that where i was
wait what
doesn't matter let me see
these people want a complicated lawyer
you give it to them but then they still
complain no i mean they weren't
complaining they were just making their
own theory they're like well i don't
think your theory is right because you
can see pharah missoula from a divine
tower where
they just didn't get what i was saying
where i i literally explained
yes i think it is physically out here to
the east but i think the version we're
in right now
is a different version than when we see
it from this divine tower
so yes we can see it i think from here
as well and here
and here
but it's different
it's not the same
considering time never changes here
so yeah
but
like i said
if i explained it good enough then
people wouldn't have gotten confused and
said that right
what am i trying to do i want a merchant
that sells
i can just go to the roundtable
they sell those there right
what's up guys today i'm gonna summon
jake from steve farm at 3am
come on i know you got him here bruh
no
all right
exactly just like the round table i
think the round table is different
um when we're in it and where it
physically is obviously it's very
different
which i said in the video just nobody
[ __ ] understood that man i i didn't i
thought i explained it good enough but
i guess i didn't
okay where is
you pass them no i
don't
i hope i didn't
they were there
you're right thank you
oh my god i'm [ __ ] blind dude
where would i be without you guys
lost
where would i be
all right let's go kill our friend
yep
yes i think time is stagnant here it
doesn't move it's stuck in time
in order to hold the dragon lord in
place
so that it doesn't die off maybe
we gotta do it for the quest line it's
what alexander wants chat
what he wants
he just wants a true battle
prepare to cry
prepare to cry again because we're gonna
kill another one of our friends
isn't he right he's right over there
okay got it
america [ __ ] up a lot of stuff dude he
[ __ ] up a lot
by shattering the ring
alexander
i am coming for you
i gotta talk alexander we'll go back man
you guys are crazy today ah
i see you finally made it here yourself
the city hanging in the air is slowly
crumbling what an incredible place we
find ourselves no kidding but that aside
you're certainly a force to be reckoned
with eh
i doubt there's a single soul who could
have handled that giant other than you
it was practically a god
of course i count myself the great
alexander among many
which means i've but one thing to ask of
you
would you kindly undertake my ordeal
come and tell me when you're ready i
don't want to man longing to fight a
warrior as accomplished as you
okay you are ready then i take it
then let us begin
no i am the great jar warrior
that is sick
i could kill him so easy though
unfortunately
i don't want to do this man
i want to do it
oh
as i suspected
victory
was impossible
this vessel
was found lacking
no
my thanks
i knew you were the stuff of champions
it was a marvelous battle
it really wasn't
take what i bequeath
from inside me all vessels are destined
to one day break
but the great alexander lived as a
warrior to his last
oh
i'm gonna bow
a warrior two is last
it was last breath
why does he have so little health
because he was never really that strong
but we won't tell him that
because he's dead now
never really that strong guys
learn pottery and rebuild him now
can i even use this shard like uh or his
talisman
let's see
greatly boost the attack power of skills
absolutely
don't really need that
okay
well
chat we killed our friend
you feel bad
why does everything that dies fade to
dust
well
i don't think there's any reason
it's a video game
go to jarburg oh my god we do we do need
to go to jarburg huh
so i killed alexander bro
[Laughter]
so he's dead now um don't know how that
happened
i don't think it's it's son right
i don't know
oh hello again cuz hey have you heard
a new potentate's come to the village
hey he's here i think he said his name
was
tialos yellows he seems a little down in
the dumps but his hands
as smooth as silk yeah because he's a
[ __ ]
let's go tell him that
i think dielos is such a weenie
yeah it's his nephew that's what it is
yellows
aha
well aren't you full of beans what do
you covered in muck
oh
my friend it's been far too long yeah i
have to say you caught me at a rather
low point but as you see
i put all that behind me left the
volcano manor forging my own path now
making my own choices
even for you me can look after some
simple jars
do you pity me
well don't
i feel like for the first time in my
life
i'm on the straight and narrow
good for you man good for you a fool i
may be
i can look after some simple jars do you
pity me
where the [ __ ] did that come austin
jesus calm down dude time in my life
okay so we talked to him
came out of nowhere
he called him a smooth potato
potenti not potato i don't know
i'm a little disappointed actually
even though good sir dialos has a
wonderful suit of armor he says he isn't
a warrior
and since he's a coward
he won't be fighting anymore
his smooth and silky hands feel nice
when he pats us
but i wish we had a potentate big and
strong like you
did you just called the alison a [ __ ]
again
god damn
i got calluses all over my hand dude
not smooth
dialysis smooth and silky hands feel
nice when he pats us
but i wish we had a potentate big and
strong like you
okay
how do i move this along
well
yellows
all right rattlesnake a fool i may be
i can look after some simple jars do you
pity me
okay uh what do i do now
my hands are hard and horny all right
then chat good for you good for you
yeah i would scratch the pots
moon but i wish leave and return i mean
i think resting does the exact same
thing i don't have to leave and come
back do i think wrestling is just
exactly the same
oh yeah we could go fight for sacks as
well
let me pass time
oh he's asleep
oh he passed out
what up paws
no wonderful
so
deals
silky
[Music]
he's dreaming about vielos's hands
warrior blood must truly run in thy
veins
good bro
a fool i made do you pity me bro
bro
he's their hero
oh no
these charges have weird fetishes
they do they truly truly do and he's
awake
all right
interesting
is he to sleep sometimes dialysis
yup
he just [ __ ] sleeps sometimes man for
uh for no reason all right let's go up
here and do what
ludwig told me to do
we're gonna leave
and now we're going back
okay
oh yeah he is our horny oh he's gone
whoa
oh
oh no
oh god
what happened oh
cause
i'm glad you came
but we're fine now
dialos fought the poacher
though quite a lot of us got broken
i won't cry though
i'm a warrior jar
a warrior i'm a warrior
the tale of house hoslow is told in
blood
that's the kind of warrior i want to be
one day cuz
if i'm scared
i'll still fight to protect
everyone
and dielos [ __ ] it all up again guys
i feel bad for this guy man
oh god
you good
you
uh are the jars
are they all right oh my god
did i defend them
[Laughter]
all right
chat what do you think
it's yes or no
sure or
no they're they're all dead man
i mean kinda
sorta is there is there an option for
kinda
he didn't defend [ __ ] he clearly he did
not
is he the only one alive
i mean
yeah
they were shattered some of them are
alive
the the one
let him have at least one good thing to
leave
okay
you did it man you're the best and all
is well
this fool proved his worth
in the end ah
yup
good job
um
all right let's go talk to him
the tale of house hoslow is told that's
the kind of even if i'm you should be uh
yeah he's dead so i don't think you want
to be like him man
does that village look defended to you
no but we can be nice
and where does he go
he's still here
what's a pity oh he's at his body
i'm glad you like the content dessert
has
ester
the tale of house hustlers oh he's yeah
he's doing the thing he's the kind of
warrior i'm going to be
one who protects everybody
he's putting his guts in his body
the tale of house oslo is told in blood
that's the kind of warrior i'm going to
be
one who protects everybody
all right
okay then
jars are gross they put the guts of
their fallen enemies into their body
into the pot
why they explode with blood
and he's gone
maybe
yep we got an item
get them the guts boy
a newman's rune
dielo's newman
eating dialysis is gonna make him weaker
dude exactly
oh he's chilling up here okay
you good bro thanks for coming back cuz
you're welcome i've been thinking
it's time for me to set out on a journey
as a warrior jar
upon the path of champions
give al oh god
what do we do do we give it to him or no
by the way here's his uh
his insides
yay or nay
give guts yes
give okay wow
cause
oh these the tarnish can be any race
from alexander
yeah
cause
oh look at his feet
so i need to be strong he's got cute
things really have them just wiggling
around right i understand
i'll get strong
strong enough
i deserve to have uncle's insights
that's a gross
quote i don't think i'll see you again
when i said to help
warriors are supposed to work alone
goodbye
cuz
and thanks for everything
i'll never forget you
because
do we kill him just kidding all right
let's go to uh
well we need to go to ronnie's tower
first which we're near this that's why
we were here actually like way earlier
and then we got distracted by jar barn
future dlc boss jar barn let's go dude
are you looking at his toes i thought
him kicking his feet were cute
do not overthink that
never forget you cause
i'm very excited to have my uncle inside
of me yep
boss spreadsheet going pretty good
we'll get there there's a ton of little
bosses
that i guess we could do like on the
last day you know
what if he gets as big as the great jar
what if the great jar is outside of time
and that is jar barn in the future
there's a potential
ooh did we go down there there's a
there's a dragon skin boss down there
nope let's continue ronnie
nerd
three
he's destined to become
giga chad himself
it would be nice character development
but i want dlc to be in the past like
the war and the capital and the dragons
me too that would be sick
i don't know what they're gonna do for
dlc there's just so many different
things that they could do
oh god i hate this area
holy [ __ ] we're almost at 63 000 subs
we just got 62 000 this morning that's
insane thank you guys
we're actually it a hundred thousand
subscribers actually looks possible
like legitimately possible so
that would be insane
100k
i could get a play button
that'd be neat
all right
[Music]
wait do you think the godskin noble will
come even though we already killed them
or do you think he won't be there
actually don't know that
[Music]
dang it
ow
man
he will still be there
man
i wonder if there's any way to kill him
before he goes down there i don't think
so
how shot was that bro
okay
okay
this is not
good what am i stuck on oh my god
[Music]
i'm just terrified
eat this area bro
[Music]
my god
[Music]
one of them
okay we're good
you guys want to do a 69 000 celebration
all right what we gonna do for that
metal asked me that earlier and i read
it and didn't say anything i'm sorry
what do we do for 69k
may want to finish milton's quest you
get the needle of mykola cause rick got
the frenzied flame we'll get we'll get
to that eventually yes
outer god rick video
okay at 69 000 i'm gonna make a parody
lore video on the soldier of god rick
or should that just be my next video we
could make a parody like meme lore video
about the soldier of godric and we could
just make a ton of [ __ ] up
that would be [ __ ] hilarious
we've been talking about that for a
while that could be really funny
meet somewhere and have a big orgy
that is an interesting idea
do you think people will get mad if i
make a meme lore video though
i'm a little worried about that
where people will be like
dude i thought you were serious about
this
it's like yeah i am but can't we have a
little fun
[Music]
the title will be
god of the lands between
soldier of god
dash rick
eldon ring lore
i might do that next i just i might make
a bunch of [ __ ] up
really funny
so weird that he's here still
i rolled
oh i thought i was gonna roll that bro i
was so close to really that we were
oh that's sick that's really cool yeah i
enjoyed that
did morbius be in the video
what if i had all of you guys
make up like a bunch of [ __ ]
okay okay i'm gonna plug our discord
this could be a really funny idea
join our discord
go into lore theories and make up
stories about rick
i'll put you in a video
if you want
could be like a fun community
video
i can't why can't oh we can use torrent
here
why can we use torrent on this
divine tower
bridge but no other one
so weird
link is in the description
rick was melania's boyfriend see go go
make up a little story go like creative
writing project
because i could make up a bunch of [ __ ]
sure but kind of be funny to see all the
stories you guys make up as well
then at the end of the video i just go
so none of this was true this was all
community
born shad the giga known for betting all
maidens in the lands between
is the father of milson
meaning
he's the husband from melania
rick is the one who taught melania the
waterfowl dance
and danced her
to sleep every single night in bed
and in training
god damn dude i can make a whole bunch
of [ __ ] up
oh ronnie
be dead
i am rick rick of rick and i have never
ripped defeat
everyone gets rick rolled at the end of
the video oh my god
that is a great idea everyone gets rick
rolled at the end dude oh my god
fantastic idea all right let's go
that's a great idea bro
i'm here fia
wait do i have runes again
yeah let's go upgrade
rick will rick roll you
don't close the video without telling
them it's jokes
yeah i know
all right our weapon is fully upgraded
voice fully upgraded
how do you not have a phone or a phone
number
but you're on youtube it's crazy
yeah i think we're going to be fine
let's go fight for the sax
[Music]
rick had to battle his brother morbius
for the morgan ring
after the battle commenced rick was aft
see there's there's no end to the
creativeness we could do for this
there's no end in sight
i remember getting people getting butt
hurt by dave controls giant dad lore
video
were they really butt hurt
are people not capable of having fun
this is the other hello brand
how did you
oh my utmost thanks
with this
godwin can take his rightful place as
first of the dead
and claim a second this is why i'm
scared of playing any other games or
making any other content from other
games
true champion
people just get so
used to butthurt can i hold you tight
if only for a moment i thought you were
the next bot video man but i guess not
just have to wait
awk in secret i will soon lay with
godwin
and it will surely stir within me
rick is placidusac's missing head oh my
god
as the rune of those who live in death
he could be all of these things do one
thing for me
brandish this child
my rune
and take for yourself the throne
stay the persecution of those who live
in death
by becoming
our elden lord
that's me
i will conceive brandish my stay the
person by becoming
you know i gotta
i gotta rest again and then get another
hug
rick is also big dad just like ratagon
is america
yeah join our discord and write some
random [ __ ] up
that'd be funny
holy a lot of you joined immediately
thank you
what if they read on soldier being
straight up actually they meant even
funny
yeah
this is goodbye my dear
but i am satisfied
i choose to lie with godwin of my own
will
not the remains of one church yeah is
rick maidenless or does he have all of
the maidens no rick has all the maidens
which is why everybody else is made in
this
but to be born a death they're all
rick's maidens
this is good okay that's it i
rick has fought many hard fights and has
never known defeat he had to get in a
reddit copyright battle
with melania because she stole his line
and she's asleep we're good
we're good
and let's go
this fight's really hard
so we'll see how we do
be tossing
i was so close to rolling there
nope
that's french
oh
i'm scared
get back here
that is so [ __ ] cool holy [ __ ]
that was a little off
dude oh it's here man
now
[Music]
now we
no it broke that i didn't even think he
got it off
oh i might be throwing right now
let me get your head
let's go first try
rick is the best
nobody can defeat rick
i don't know why this fight exists
because it's awesome and there's a
backstory to it
he's inside of godwin's mind
she's still asleep here
okay we got the mending rune of death
which gives us that ending if we want it
he looks dead
i am rick roll of ass
and i've never been rick roll
yeah we're inside of godwin's mind there
do you still do this boss if you kill
fia no
that would be the whole
whole dealio there and now she's dead
take a good long look
see the wrath of the golden order the
orders justice writ in
this is what's become of your precious
witch
naught but expired meat and bone
this is a proper death oh prince
look at this rotten hall
no more children can be got from this
useless flesh
behold
your mother is dead
cat do we kill him
we let him go
this is revenge you witch and you you
cool
this is the wrath of d
ah these nuts hello
the rotten witch is dead the rotten
witch is dead
unsullied
now i can look my brother darian in the
eye what's that from honeyed rays of
gold he gone the witch is dead the had
the witches dead
the rotten witch is dead
now i have no regrets definitely kill
him rays of gold
deliver my spirit
yep the wrath of d right how about the
wrath
of these nuts
shut up
[Music]
how could this
forgive me
good job chat
yep wizard a boss
how about no you die
okay so
man we're kind of cooking today we've
done a lot today huh let's check our
list
so
we just killed for the saks
so we're done here
we killed commander nile
good job good job
we killed borealis very nice
altis plateau i don't think we've gone
there today
lemieux i don't think we've gone here
today either
who else have we fought we've done a lot
of questing
so
i think with the rest of these right we
could pretty oh we killed a steel did i
already mark that off
that would be
[Music]
lake of rot so yeah we we got that we
killed the godskin duo
through
which is
crumbly for missoula got him
we gotta fight these two
good good
tomorrow mogwin palace and ordina puzzle
paws champ
yeah we might have to come back tomorrow
because wow we've been going three and a
half hours already holy [ __ ]
yeah we can come back tomorrow and go at
this again
i think we can pretty much get through
the rest of the game without messing up
any quest lines um
well we need we need to do millicent
which mil we've done everything we need
to do for millicent except for um
we need to go to the halogen tree which
we started that process so that's good
gotta go to mogwin's palace
so we we still have a lot to do i i
could say we could get it done in like
15
episodes so like five more days
and we might be able to get everything
done maybe even less depending on how
far we go
but i think we've done a good amount of
stuff today chat
some other things that i want to get
done today i also want to work on this
video now you guys got me all excited
about it
got me real excited about it it's a good
idea for a soldier of godric video
soldier of god rick excuse me
yeah it looks like you guys are writing
stuff
yeah but join our discord yeah i think
i'm gonna be done for today so join our
discord
write whatever you want um about rick if
if you want to or other things that you
may have may have known about um
we'd love to have you in there discord's
growing all the time a lot of people
talking in there all things elden ring
as well so love to have you um that's
another thing i want to plug
dude follow me on twitter please i hate
tweeting and getting like one like it
makes me sad okay so
follow me on twitter if you got it
everything's linked in the description
by the way
uh if you want early access to videos
you can join our patreon that's growing
every single day i really appreciate the
extra support so you get uh videos early
with no ads as well
so if you'd like that that's an option
for you
uh other than that we'll be back
tomorrow guys we're gonna keep keep the
stream going i like streaming like three
four five hours every time so this is
good
um
yeah i appreciate you love you guys
thank you for all the support
really close to 63 000 subs which is
kind of insane can't believe that is
actually a thing
so
thank you very much you guys are great
um
yeah we'll be back tomorrow so i hope
you all have a great rest of your day
and i'll see you guys then
peace and love
take care have a good one bye bye boy
yeah great